[Music]
I was always intrigued and about real
estate and invest in real estate and I'd
read articles when I was 13 years old I
bought multiscript in the Wall Street
Journal and so it did interest me a
possible career in real estate but you
know I really didn't know which
direction I wanted to go until really I
was in in high school and first year of
college my name is Roy Carroll and I'm
the CEO president of the Carroll
companies
[Music]
thank you
growing up as a very lower middle class
upbringing I both my parents worked my
father was a meat cutter grocery store
man I did a little bit of remodeling on
the side so I'd go help him you know
after school on weekends with remodel
jobs so that's how I got my hands in
construction a little bit we actually
lived in rental homes we didn't even own
our own homes I was in high school
after my father bought his first house
he decided to buy some more rental homes
and get an opportunity to buy two homes
up in Danville Virginia and I'd saved up
money mowing loans doing odd jobs and
such and so I'd saved a thousand dollars
and so this is a very modest home and so
he asked me if I wanted to buy the one
home and so I I put a thousand dollars
down and owner finance I think it's four
thousand dollars or so this is five
thousand dollar home and I rented it for
a year and uh sold it for a profit uh to
buy a car which is a bad investment
because cars depreciate value right I
should have kept that house
so I was in college and my father got
laid off from his grocery store business
after 20 some years this early 80s
terrible time to go to Real Estate
interest rates are very high we had some
friends that wanted a house built and so
they knew my father done some
Renovations on the side and so they
asked my father if he wanted to build
their house
I was going to school here locally and
so I would help after school and on
weekends and and he and I did a lot of
the work Hands-On when I say did the
work we nailed the nails and swept the
floors and did things like that and
built the first house and by the time
we'd finished that home actually had
another set of friends that said hey you
did a good job with that home why don't
you would you be interested in building
us a home and so after building a second
house he and I kind of sat down and said
you know we we may be able to make a
career out of this and so we formed our
little company and started doing custom
homes on scattered Lots around the
Greensboro area
we kind of divvied up the worlds he
would run the cruise on the job site
more so and I would do more of the
estimating and selections with the
customers you know we still both got out
there and drove nails at the end of the
day so it was very rewarding and
everything that those early years
starting the business of my father
[Music]
real estate business has a lot of risk
associated and from the first year that
we started the business we decided that
we would my father had a little bit of
retirement savings that he lived I was a
college student so it didn't take much
for me to live on so we decided we'd pay
our sales once a year at the end of the
year so we basically put a third of the
profits back into the business to grow
it and we'll each take a third and so as
long as he was in the business up until
the early 90s that's that's the way we
paid ourselves and so I think that was
one of the things that kind of was a
catalyst for us to be as successful as
we were is just that very conservative
approach which I carry on today
we've got a Hyatt Place Hotel right
downtown we'll have 300 Apartments
associated with it we're getting ready
to start an AC hotel across the street
from it rooftop restaurant another 300
apartment Associated we've got I don't
know how many Bee safes we have in town
here and whenever we start a new Venture
a new project new idea we always like to
try it out in our backyard where we can
kind of tweak it a little bit get the
formula just right before we take it on
the road
we're always looking for markets that
are emerging in areas where there's new
growth and opportunity and we're also
looking for Value we're not going to go
out there and be the the guys that bid
and pay top dollar for a real estate
asset we really beat the bushes hard so
to speak and try to find Value and then
try to add to that value by executing
and the vertical construction or if it's
an existing building we will go in and
renovate and invest dollars into you
know reposition it to to a nice place
well remodeling a building is a lot more
brain damage Associated because you
don't know what you're going to get into
and the building we're sitting in here
was 17-story buildings old Wachovia Bank
building it was built between 63 and 64
and then it was basically abandoned in
the early 80s and so it gone through
bankruptcy a couple times and insurance
company Next Door Lincoln Financial had
purchased the building and they really
purchased to protect their assets
because they owned several buildings
downtown and several other properties
and this is kind of sitting in the
middle of them and so I met with the CEO
of the company and convinced him that
you know we could execute this project
could turn into something that
Greensboro will be proud of and so we we
lined up that we want to do condos as
you know this is a mid mid to 2005 2006
we're doing the planning people lined up
to buy condos from us and and so we
started construction we had about half
the condos pre-sold and then 2008 hit in
2009 you're hearing just about every day
about a developer who did a condo
project and and they got sideways and
they were turning it back over to the
bank and I told people I said I will not
give this building back to the bank by
speaking to the CFO one morning and I
said you know I think I think it would
help us sell more condos and just take
that cloud from Over the Carroll
companies if we just paid off this
building and hindsight is one of the
smartest things we could have done
because word got on the street that you
know that's how we conduct business
we're not going to walk away from one of
our obligations and you know we never
reduced the price of one condo in this
building and uh you know we're we're
close to sold out and everything so and
I live here so all my neighbors are
happy with me because I didn't reduce
the price or give it back to the bank so
it turned out well for everyone here
[Music]
foreign
storage kind of like a close cousin to
multi-family anyways the way I see it
and a lot of our communities we already
had garages we had storage units outside
so I studied the business and I said
let's let's come up with something
that's a little bit unique there's a lot
of good self storage operators out there
today and so we came up with the be safe
brand and where we tried to position be
safe is that it is top end of the market
our lighting's a little brighter we
temper the temperatures inside a little
bit more than most cell storage
operators and we put a lot of money in
the exterior facade all of our exteriors
and to be safe or or stone and brick and
they really look like an office building
so they fit in well in the upscale
communities that we're trying to be and
so that's been a good business model for
us and and you know we're spread out
pretty much everywhere where we're
already with the multi-family we're also
looking to put be safe self storage
facilities
[Music]
thank you
car storage is something that we've
studied there's a number of different
variations of car storage across the
country where we're a little bit
different and we're doing it instead of
doing like a condo or one big open space
where we're placing cars and and a big
open room these are individual uh
two-story units that we lease we give
you an upfit allowance where you can
personalize It Whatever theme you want
to come up with I'm into cars a little
bit some collecting and I thought it was
a would go well with some of the other
car events that I attend and be able to
promote it with some of our be safe
racing
I guess about five years ago I bought a
Fray challenge car and would take it up
there's a there's a race track about an
hour north of here in Virginia and uh
was running around one day in the race
team uh was looking to form down in
Charlotte and asked me if I'd be
interested in joining them on the
Ferrari Challenge Series and so I said
sure and so uh one thing led to another
and joined the team and met a lot of
great people being involved with that
it's great to be involved with Ferrari
it's helping us brand it's also helped
with Employee Engagement and Carol
companies uh several employees like to
follow the our racing program and it's
great that it's kind of pulled a lot of
our Carroll companies employees together
and everything around the racing program
we had a car in Le Mans this year
partnered with Ferrari for a racing
program built a Ferrari 488 GTE for us
to run in Le Mans and we we had a good
experience with that came in fifth in
our class so we'll be back at some point
in the future and be on the podium one
day
well this community Greensboro has been
very good to me and my family over the
years obviously and so you know we're
very blessed to be able to give back to
the community and it is rewarding to
look out the window of our home here and
and see various projects we we have
ongoing some sometimes I look out the
window to see something though that hey
that needs to be changed
Greensboro is a beautiful place it's a
great place to live great place to grow
up and real blessed to be here
[Music]